hey guys Ryan right here in Katy Du Bois
we're gonna watch this short film today
called TIE fighter Star Wars inspired LT
it's t gonna be different
I'm Alicia these TIAA just proof that I
have not seen this and have no idea what
we're about
oh it's gonna be genuine reaction okay
we should stop plus with the bomb
yeah okay long time ago I heard this
took like four years to make okay
[Music]
[Music]
asleep
it's like Star Wars and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I really want more
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the dark side that has ever looked
you
got it coming
should be a great era Terry
[Music]
No
how are you
like it was
the joy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I love it it feels like very easy
[Music]
music to
[Music]
[Music]
gen-i
[Music]
they have come
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're just not doing it against in our
Center
[Music]
[Music]
so that the dark side they won that
battle the door said he did win huh yeah
oh it starts off with them like hey
we're probably gonna win and then they
win Wow it was that evil guys start
table name just goes right down it's
merely about like the theme and the
style in the tone that was really neat
to watch like a animes take on Star Wars
and then turn it's like an 80s vibe it's
a yeah yeah it reminded me sort of a GI
Joe is that weird like if GI Joe with
Star Wars no that's not weird that's
weird I mean it's not something that
everyone would say I don't want to you
know just the sort of angular white guy
why is everyone in space wait cuz
they're the dominant race right hmm is
that a fact
why is it called tie-fighter I think
it's like a reference to like an old
cartoon isn't that why do you look
bummed out I look bummed I don't really
I never I didn't wasn't allowed to
watching TV as a kid oh that's sad so I
don't really know what I'm talking about
but it feels like a no mods like it
feels like two worlds combines yeah yeah
no II mean I kind of get a Gundam vibe
too yeah Gundam Wing yeah
I've seen like two episodes all right
yes I'm a huge fan I think this could be
a really cool show if they oh yeah like
you know is the money some money and if
they got dialogue
yeah there I like seeing this whole
battle sequence take place it was about
really showing if they could showing off
the Star Wars action and it looks great
it looked [ __ ] amazing it was
beautiful to look at I was lost in it
and I think that if they did a show that
would be really cool because an anime
take on Star Wars come on imagine if
they work on Jedi's that is gonna be
[ __ ] sweet imagine those battles huh
yeah complete space complete space space
battle space space battles Space wars
space Wars
mm-hmm baseballs if you guys are new to
the channel guess what you can do you
can subscribe to the real rejects Katie
has a channel you can subscribe to her
channel too
oh you follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter well you can't follow her on
Instagram because she's a she's little
brat it's like a Google because I don't
go on like I can't care about everything
right and I don't
dan Hill hi guys
love your video so much I'm a huge fan
not sure what I would do without your
videos keep up the great work
regards Dan Oh regards regards oh you
like that copper gentleman oh wow she's
attracted to gentlemen or Cowboys yeah
yeah that's basically no big range of
yeah there's a lot in between keep up
the great work he capitalized great yes
this is great work I think this is a lot
of time I put into it each video can
take up to like 15 minutes to film and
editing could take like 20 after that
was exhausted do you want a slow clap
Wow watch fun which usually you would do
without your VIP about our videos you
would use all that time and energy to
become a scholar come on Katie
you've been on a channel enough to go
and masturbate dude oh masturbation come
on
I set us up for that I'm trying I try
pal you mean that one to you it was like
I wasn't there I wasn't in the headspace
I'm sorry no no you were not in the head
space at all I'm not a fetus me again
hmm
what does everything sound like a
naughty jokes yeah I got it
yeah problems of it